[Applause]
yeah yeah you want
yeah yeah it was i mean nashville we
have so many people moving there from
california
yeah yeah and uh i mean they're coming
it's a it's insane there's like a
problem 100 people a day moved to
nashville
and then it's a lot of people from
california the wonderful thing is i
think though
maybe some of the a lot of them going to
austin yes and so like
that's better that's better in austin
well i think you go yeah you
they our goal in nashville is you like
the ones we don't want go to also
and then the other ones come to come i
heard they just made um
the jews illegal in nashville yeah oh
then we got to move there
yeah yeah yeah is that true
uh i don't know i mean i didn't see it
in the paper it was in the newspaper
it wasn't yeah no yeah i don't we you
know i never met a jewish person so i
lit
that was a stereotype
we moved to new york uh but it's funny
that was always a stereotype but they
said southern people
hate jews and you're like i've never
grew up in texas i didn't know what
i knew jews existed but i didn't know
that i didn't know that that was like
it's like a well because white supremacy
or but like they hate and you're like
i don't know dude you're like i didn't
i'm just not around any jewish people
like i don't yeah i was funny
i thought there just were none there
coastal easter eggs is from texas yeah
and they treat white southerners the way
they think you treat black people like
they look at you and they're like look
at this [ __ ] uneducated
ignorant lazy blah blah blah and that's
how they think you treat black people
you know it's funny i don't mind doing
it but like if people from outside of
america do it i'm like yo
slow down yeah those are our guys to
make fun
like exactly it's like you can make fun
of your little brother but nobody else
can make fun of your little brother
but i wonder yeah i don't know you guys
don't have that relationship with us you
guys just kind of like hate us
up north huh we uh
it's tough because you know when i lived
there so like giannis right we embraced
you bro
yeah i know we loved you i know well i
like dude i love new york and all my
friends are from new york and uh
but when like giannis was a perfect
example so when the honest
when me and giannis moved there yonas
would always tell me i have no culture
right and i was like
dude you've never lived three blocks
from your mom
like i was in new york like i moved i've
changed my whole
world yeah and like just because you're
like you know you got a guy from nigeria
and then
the jewish people and whatever and
everybody from all these you think like
you get the world
yeah yeah they live near you like yeah
and then i
i had an old joke about it uh where i
said the melting pot thing whereas like
new york is a big melting pot yeah but
just a bunch of pots don't live next to
their own kinds of pots i mean
yeah you're not mixed in at all dude you
have a chinatown that you like don't
come under
this area little italy and you're like
you're like i don't y'all hate each
other
like i don't understand yeah yeah so
that's what so moving to new york was
yeah it's a melting pot until like
another ethnic group
encroaches on your neighborhood yeah and
then it's a big problem
yeah yeah then we're not really a stew
at all yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's the italians in brooklyn yeah how
much of a stew there yeah yeah
it's all the it's the same it's a big
issue it's all the same dude
yeah yeah so yeah so no i don't we you
know
new york is uh yeah i don't know it's
like you would feel that though it's
like everybody just thinks you're like
what are you like some everybody
pre-judges you i remember a guy saying
it once
where they were like uh it was like this
gay dude he was like oh
he goes you know nate's from the south
or something they're like oh he's like a
republican that hates gays and stuff and
you're like you're doing what you think
i do to you and i don't
yeah and you're doing it to me and
that's what's so crazy and then they
tell you that to your face like that
the person that said i was an
anti-vaxxer there's some seriousness to
what she's
what she said yes you said that and you
want to go i'm not
i didn't walk in here and think you're
one thing yeah i'm meeting you and just
enjoying talking to you yeah but you
immediately say that and you say it to
my face
yeah and like don't even care yeah
that's crazy where you're like
you're like and then you're like why do
you hate us you're like i don't know
maybe that
maybe every you think i'm stupid
auditioning for uh they sent you a movie
audition are you a southern guy
and you're like you gotta be i mean
you're just the most
i remember you getting movie auditions
and they're being like you're going to
have to yell the n word you're like why
would i
do that and they're like that's because
what y'all do like you think that's what
we do
dude and they think that is a you're in
just a movie and that's the best part
you think i can be is just this guy
yeah you're like ah get in you just
don't do them what was the movie
dude you in 12 years of slave would be
hysterical yeah
what i'm 12 years slave it would be
accurate that'd be yeah there'd be a lot
of yelling
yeah a lot of edward yelling yeah yeah
but i mean i you know i grew up in i was
born in 79 so i don't know
yeah we weren't doing it
weren't it wasn't happening i mean they
talk about that a lot with like they
think like
you know white supremacy like dude i
wasn't i've been in the south my whole
life i've never
met a clan member yeah i've never been
around one like i don't know
yeah you know i'm not saying that they
don't exist you got to say that all the
time but like
i don't they're not around me it's not
like i'm just in the car with them not
as prevalent as
people make it out to be i never they
make it like they're just
i mean like they're yeah like they're
running the town
and you're like i don't know dude we
just grew up in like
we just grew up like everybody else grew
up and why do you think that is
just like movies and [ __ ] oh yeah i
think so i think so i mean
when you were growing up watching tv and
movies was it annoying
were you like why does everybody talk
like me stupid uh or you don't even
realize it
i don't know when i realized it i didn't
realize that until i moved to chicago
like
it was because you know when you're in
nashville you're just around your you
know everybody went to church
yeah everybody went to like it was uh
airborne was just
there was you know like if you were a
christian growing up i mean everybody
was i mean you went to church like you
would ask people
where they go to church over like where
they go to high school like that's
a very yeah you're like what church you
go to then they would just tell you like
oh yeah i know
someone i have a buddy that goes to
church like it was just everybody went
to church
and uh and then you moved to chicago
when i moved to chicago i remember
someone
they were angry that uh like i grew up
going to church and i was like okay
and because then they but they think
christians like southern baptist
they think oh this is crazy think you're
like dude it's just a regular church
like we weren't
but through their head they are holding
snakes you're like doing all this kind
of stuff and you're like
we're not doing any of this stuff like i
don't and you gotta defend it and
they're like no that's what y'all do
i mean they are people are so judgmental
yeah and they judge so hard yeah
and you know stuff bad stuff exists but
you're like i don't
you know there's a lot of regular people
that are just minding their own
business what were you shocked by like
when you came to new york and la
well probably not as much la right
because you've already experienced but
like new york specifically what were you
shocked by
were you expecting it to be way
different and then it just wasn't
uh i mean it was overwhelming i remember
i'm trying to think of what
specifically i remember coming out of
the subway once and being just very
confused
and like you're just it's very very
overwhelming it's so many people
yeah uh i guess like everybody
you know i didn't think they were as
mean as everybody
said they were yeah i thought new york
wasn't like that yeah like uh
you always hear that everybody's just
super rude there and you're like
then once you're there i represent that
yeah we're nice people
i think it's very nice move to new york
that feel like they have to live up to
the stereotype of a movie they start
acting mean towards one another but like
actual new yorkers are usually pretty
helpful i think
there's just an impatience like they
have to get where the [ __ ] they need to
get and if you're in the way of that
you're a problem
yeah but you know walking slow you're a
problem yeah yeah but you know it's not
going to be
like it's not going to be a long drawn
thing like you're not going to fight
about it like
right they they yell at you and then
they forget about you
and like so it's like you kind of
learned to not take things personal
yeah and then uh because you're like
it's yeah it's like dude they want to
just go
and you're like oh yeah sorry man and
then they just roll by you
you